we've never been to gangkon i've never
been to mexico never been to mexico
never but where should i go straight or
right
that's the way
i guess straight
i don't know either just pick one i'm
not going straight
the car behind us is kind of scaring me
how fast i know
or something
please what
they're white they're white they're
white they're white they're white
they're white that that's what they said
that's what the [ __ ] they said
also appreciate the guy on the left was
like at the beginning like just drive
just drive and you was like no
that was the right reaction because had
they driven off they might have actually
thought that they were a rival car
they would have just fired yeah yeah so
if you ever get in one of these
situations just driving off really
rapidly may not be your best solution
oh man hey
hey
you know what
it's not funny
it's kind of fun
oh man there's a wonderful saying in
creole i really love that that's saying
i love that expression
it it says a lot
um
tough things said by parents
it's a great thing it's uh
whenever you tell you not to do
something
and you still do it
and then you end up bumping your head
you know what i mean
they tell you instead of consoling you
and telling you oh it's going to be all
right
oh do you have a boo boo and they kiss
the boo boo and stuff like that they go
sakthevoyo
are you crying i'm gonna give you a
reason to cry sakta voil means who sent
you who sent you who sent you oh you
know what we're gonna go in a wonderful
voyage let's go on a trip it's not
already good that you took the plane
you're in on the destination you want to
go
on ventures
drive through mexico driving through
mexico those were dirt roads that's why
that [ __ ] was so bumpy oh my god they
got guns oh my god yeah
please what
no espanol please
wait wait wait you're gonna go on an
adventure and that's how you sound when
you speak spanish
say it
ah no
thank god
that's your spanish us no
no evil doer no crime in my car please
espanol uh um
burrito
i could dabble in spanish and i would
never gone on adventures like oh we're
just vibing out here in mexico
bruh like i don't i really don't want to
laugh
but
[ __ ] sack devo yo moshe
i just wish these guys were doing this
in africa and some somalian pirates just
rolled up on them and were like
what are you gay
that would have been perfect
hi my name is dr martin semper
you are going to eat the poopoo later on
in cancun we are going to stop you we
are going to send you back to your
country for this is deviant it is a
sickness and we do not want it in mexico
that's that like i want to have i want
to feel bad for you but i really don't
that's your level of spanish i'm going
to need you to just slow it down with
the victim blaming i would like to
understand the victim's experience
yeah we just want we're just
how is this even possible amen that you
decide that oh my god basic basic basic
tip okay
do not be driving any back roads in
countries where you do not speak the
language and there's levels of danger
most mexicans will tell you it's not
even safe to go down these roads you are
a for mexicans
you are a firefighter and you're out
here driving like you're like oh senora
like no that's not you scott you don't
roll your arse you're a 0.54 okay you
say tacos you go like oh my god mexican
food's amazing burritos it's not that's
not mexican
you can't you can't
oh my god you know what this is this is
this is entitlement this is entitlement
to be able to go to these places and
think you can just drive on these roads
and think you're supposed to be safe is
absolute entitlement that's the only way
i could put it
i went i went to mexico i went to mexico
a couple of times you know what i did
what i stayed my ass at the resort yeah
why
why not
huh
the only taxi that we took was a cab
that we took from the hotel that was a
cab taxi from the hotel
we went to eat a bit scenery
uh playa del carmen it's like as i said
like i took a a a cab to downtown
montreal okay and i went the [ __ ] back
that way i didn't go oh we could walk at
the hotel it's a nice walk
what what hold on we went to playa del
carmen and after that we went back to
the the hotel that's it and some of my
friends are watching sometimes and you
know what yeah you yeah y'all guys
sometimes you guys you'll be dogging me
because i go to resort
that's not the real experience no play
please please
please what
maybe i'm not trying to have the real
experience
i goodness my face is [ __ ]
maybe please please
hey no
no no no no no no no hey okay
where are you from jesus christ it's
simple answer the question god damn well
you know now you just got me pissed off
you know i gotta defend them i gotta
defend them clearly these guys are just
lost and they're they're terrified when
someone is that scared like they're not
gonna be able to answer simple questions
fair
you know what i mean like fair the man's
trying to talk to him and try to calm
him down but these people have heard of
the car town just realized they're
coming face to face with so they're
thinking in their head i'm about to get
beheaded yes i'm going back home to my
family in limbs you're not but what you
don't know is that the cartel doesn't
take gay hostages
[Laughter]
oh you ain't [ __ ] for this one what
[Music]
god damn it's just oh my god
yeah yeah you know i yeah you're right
but i'm just saying brother hey man this
is one of those privileges i'm just
telling you
i'm not
she [ __ ] up bro it's like gay dudes
and black folks we don't make for great
hostages we let go if we get legal
that's a privilege you know what i'm
saying because people
situation and they're like yo
we got [ __ ] abdul and jamar they're
like
who
what's your name
you're kind of cute
what's your name erin and your name
logan yeah would have been hilarious
the cartel members just like
you kind of cute
you want to [ __ ]
not even that
you're gay
who's bigger than he just pulls out
say hello tomorrow
oh yeah
okay
oh my god
no no no don't go down
hey
here you need your medicine you know no
no here take aaron
no probably no problem yeah
okay okay
take it now put it under your tongue put
it under your tongue
oh my god
logan i can't the hands are okay i'll
drive the trade
[Applause]
i said what i said do you want to go on
a whole adventure
[ __ ]
let's go see scenery you know what there
are tours for that you know what i mean
you go on a tour store you know they
show you places there's some you know
birds and [ __ ] yeah you take those
take those know where you're going
yeah yeah the food's good the the the
the scenery might be cool no also other
things okay what the dangers are just
have a bit of situation listen when we
have a bit of situational awareness is
all i'm trying to say because if you're
not willing to do that while you're
traveling these guys are fortunate that
they could put this video up and upload
it and share with everyone that they're
still alive but most people end up in
the situation they end up on the five
o'clock news or they have you see this
and people like oh my god they're
victims but at the same time it's like
you're driving in rural roads in mexico
in a country where even local mexicans
wouldn't do this so casually and
flippantly like you did how am i
supposed to feel bad you know what i'm
saying like you what you're doing as a
foreigner what the locals would not do
as locals does that make sense that
makes perfect sense that's what i'm
saying
what did you guys feel about the
situation could this have been avoided
and if you guys liked today's video
leave a like and a comment all right it
helps out that algorithm
oh my god